et de moscou a condamné aujourd'hui
avoir pulvérisé un satellite en orbite
au cours de ce tir d'essai on retrouve
tout de suite notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman dans la capitale russe
cette fois verra alors comment
réagissent les autorités russes après
ces accusations
bonsoir stéphanie l'hypocrisie c'est le
mot utilisé par le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov pour qualifier la
réaction des états unis quant aux tirs
de missiles antisatellites russe le
ministre a également dénoncé
l'ambivalence des états unis au sujet de
la militarisation de l'espace je vous
propose d'écouter
affirmé que la russie est à l'origine de
risques qui pèserait sur l'utilisation
pacifique de l'espace relève pour le
moins de l'hypocrisie
comme vous l'avez justement remarquer il
n'y a aucune preuve de cela mais je vais
vous donner d'autres faits les
etats-unis nous appelle comme ils le
disent à développer des normes
universelles pour l'exploration spatiale
mais depuis des années qu'ils négligent
l'initiative de la russie et de la chine
concernant la préparation de la corse la
prévention de la course aux armements
dans l'espace
il a négligent tout simplement en
insistant sur l'établissement des normes
de conduite
néanmoins les etats-unis eux-mêmes
développe cette course aux armements
très activement
le ministère russe de la défense a
également réagi aux déclarations
américaines en réfutant la possibilité
d'une menace créée à la station spatiale
internationale et les cosmonautes
écouter
en 2020 les états unis ont créé le space
com end et ont adopté officiellement une
nouvelle stratégie spatiale dont l'un
des principaux objectifs est de créer un
avantage militaire globale dans l'espace
à son tour le pentagone avant même ces
mesures officielles et encore plus après
développe activement et s en orbite sans
aucune notification ses dernières armes
d'attac et de combats de divers types y
compris les dernières versions de la
navette spatiale sans pilote x 37 les
actions de la partie américaine sont
considérés comme une menace
et sont incompatibles avec les objectifs
déclarés d'utilisation pacifique de
l'espace ce thé russe de la défense a
admis donc avoir détruit ce lundi un
satellite russe en affirmant que les
activités que la russie mène dans
l'espace sont planifiés et vise à
renforcer sa capacité de défense et les
autorités russes ont également appelé à
mettre en place des normes universelles
de l'exploration spatiale pour la
communauté internationale merci beaucoup
verhaeghe hoffman en direct de moscou